ces sources d'eau douce ne constituent
que le prélude un long voyage situé dans
les hauteurs des andes
elles aboutiront avec d'autres
innombrables au fleuve le plus long de
la terre l'amazone
gonflé de poussière de roche et de boue
elles sont déjà riche de substances
nutritives elle dévale les pentes à une
vitesse impressionnante et toutes les
créatures qui vivent se doivent de nager
à la perfection ce qui est le cas des
maires gagnent est armé ou camardes et
oran
ces oiseaux exploite les remous et les
tourbillons avec une habileté consommer
pagayant puissamment grâce à leurs
pattes palmées et remonte le courant il
s'ancre au rocher avec leur queue et
pour assurer leur prise utilise de
petits éperon corner situé à
l'articulation de leurs ailes mais qu'y
at il à manger dans ces eaux froides et
tumultueuse on y trouve de la mousse
comme dans tous les cours d'eau du monde
une mousse qui procure à l'abri à une
multitude de larves d'insectes
en étaient ces créatures viendront
brièvement voler au dessus de la rivière
pour s'accoupler
mais l'essentiel de leur vie se passera
sous l'eau certains sont littéralement
profiler pour résister au courant les
larves des frais gamme s'abritent dans
des tubes protecteur le creux d'un
roseau ou une construction de débris de
bois en bâtissant leur abri à base de
lure grain de sable
certaines se l'est elle même afin que le
courant ne les emporte pas la larve de
la simulie se maintient un caillou par
une sorte de crochet même si elle perd
prise tout n'est pas perdu
un fil de soi une sorte de ligne de
survie la relier à son attache
en remontant ce fil elle regagne son
port pour s'y assurer une nouvelle prise
par sa glande filière elle déroule un
tampon de soi très fines auxquelles elle
s'amarrera nouveau la simulie à
développer des antennes modifié sorte de
filet avec lesquels elles capturent sa
nourriture
les petits cours d'eau qui dévallent les
pentes de la vallée pour alimenter les
fleuves naissant ont leur propre
population en malaisie et les tortues à
grosse tête ou plati sternum de sons
aquatiques
elle remonte les chutes d'eau en se
servant de leur queue très longue comme
point d'appui dans ses autres chutes en
afrique occidentale et nulle part
ailleurs ville extraordinaire grenouille
poilus les poils en question sont en
fait des filaments implanté sur ses
flancs et qui lui sert de branchies pour
absorber l'oxygène de l'eau autres
appendices inhabituel ses griffes qui
l'aident à s'agripper au caillou
dévalant d'une hauteur de 15 100 m les
innombrables sources qui alimentent
l'amazone rejoignent les eaux brunes
d'un véritable affluent épaissi par la
boue et les sédiments le débit du
torrent charriant sables et graviers
ce culte à présent les flancs de la
montagne
quand le courant se heurte à une roche
plus dur telle une ancienne coulée de
basalte
sa progression est temporairement
contrarié il passe par dessus la
barrière en à pic
ainsi se forment les plus belles
cascades comme ces chutes d'iguaçu aux
frontières du brésil du paraguay et de
l'argentine
à la base le flou frappe les roches
jusqu'à ce qu'elle se fend d'un si les
chutes tracent leur chemin vers laval en
laissant en amont des gorges profondes
des animaux vivent ici à l'intérieur
même des chutes comme ces martinet qui
nichent sur la façade rocheuse derrière
la cascade
chaque jour ils se rassemblent très haut
au dessus du fleuve iguaçu après une
partie de chasse aux insectes
il rallie leur nid en jaillissant à
travers l'écran aquatique qui les
protégera pour la nuit
et le fleuve s'éloigne elle est 100
derrière lui ses sources montagneuse
son aspect a changé ses eaux se sont
enrichis en éléments nutritifs
au fil de l'amazone la jungle s'épaissit
des oiseaux comme le choral soleil se
promène en quête de nourriture des
normes poisson croiser dans les eaux qui
s'écoulent plus lentement
lara payement un des plus grands
poissons d'eau douce
il mesure près de deux mètres l'amazone
contient près de 3000 espèces de
poissons différents
les poissons chats demeure au fond du
fleuve leurs antennes sensitive leur
permettent de se frayer un chemin à
travers les fonds les plus boon
certains d'entre eux sont capables de se
défendre en déchargeant de l'électricité
d'autres possèdent des ventouses
ventrale ou dorsales qui leur permettent
de s'agripper au rocher rien qu'en
amérique du sud on recense 12 cents
espèces différentes de ces poissons
chats
dans ces eaux surpeuplée beaucoup de
poissons offrent à leurs progénitures
une protection particulière
celui ci le disque us va plus loin il
procure à ses petits un menu particulier
une sécrétion visqueuse spécial qu'il
produit sur ses flancs et dont ils se
nourrissent
plus le fleuve évolue plus il ralentit
son cours le moindre obstacle suffit à
le freiner
à l'extérieur de chaque courbe le flux
érode la rive à l'intérieur de la courbe
là où le courant est plus lent l'eau
dépose sa charge de sédiments ainsi avec
le temps qui passe les courbes du fleuve
sera proches les unes des autres
au fil des ans elles prennent le chemin
le plus court
les terres qui les sépare finissent par
s'effondrer le fleuve raccourci son
tracé
à la longue certes un méandre deviennent
des lacs rapidement envahi par la
végétation
ses feuilles sont celles du célèbre
victoria régia le nénuphar géant de
l'amazone une plante aquatique agressive
qui se développe au détriment de celle
plus modeste qui l'entourent au départ
ces feuilles ont la taille d'une
assiette à soupe en quelques jours elles
atteignent 2 mètres de diamètre soit une
croissance de quelque 3 centimètres
carrés par minute lors nervures rempli
d'air leur font supporter le poids de
lourd aux oiseaux aquatiques tels le
jacana auquel des pâtes audois largement
étalé permettent d'ailleurs de se
déplacer sur des feuilles bien moins
résistantes
il se nourrit d'insectes et il n'a ici
que l'embarras du choix
cette hydre au maître est installé sur
une feuille mais il pourrait l'être
aussi confortablement sur la surface de
l'eau car celle ci constitue une
plateforme tout à fait susceptible de
supporter de petites créatures et
molécules d'eau sont reliées entre elles
par une force de cohésion qui crée en
surface une tension relativement ferme
l'hydro m transperce sa victime et se
nourrit de sa substance
le film de tension qui se forment à la
surface de l'eau ne sert pas seulement
de plateforme aux insectes
il constitue également une caisse de
résonance qui leur permet de détecter la
proche d'une 3 de faire des signes d'
alerte ou de lancer des messages de
séduction
le no tô nect comme l'hydro m patrouille
à la surface à la recherche d'une proie
mais sous marine celle là ainsi ces deux
insectes se partagent l'essentiel de ce
qui peut être pris au piège sur cette
pellicule aquatique ce coléoptère qui
vit sur les plantes des berges à
quelques talents divers il évolue à la
surface de l'eau avec une particulière
agilité il est capable aussi de produire
une substance qui le propulse à une
vitesse accélérée
enfin entre autres performances et comme
la plupart des coléoptères les mêmes
capables de voler l'amazone charrie une
masse de sédiments couleur ocre depuis
ces sources des andes jusqu'à sa
jonction avec le rio negro qui lui ne
charrie que des hausses en limon
seulement à thé de noir ou de verre par
des substances organiques 10 août car
ils descendent du nord ouest où les
terres sont constitué de roches dures et
nu pendant plusieurs kilomètres les deux
fleuves ne mélange pas leur zoo qui
foisonne de nourriture et la vie sur les
berges est florissante des hordes de
rongeurs géant les capybaras ou cabié il
prospère
ces animaux amphibie sont d'excellents
nageurs leurs pieds sont palmés leurs
yeux leurs oreilles et leurs narines
sont tous situés sur le sommet de leur
tête ce qui leur permet lorsqu'il
pénètre dans l'eau de continuer à voir à
entendre et à sentir ce qui les
environne en surface les loutres géantes
ont des caractéristiques physiques
similaires
cette espèce amazonienne bat tous les
records de taille certains spécimens
atteignent près de deux mètres de long
il s'agit d'une vaste famille
représentée dans beaucoup de fleuve aux
quatre coins du monde une multitude
d'oiseaux revendique également sa part
de pêche dans le fleuve
voici un arles couronnais c'est une
espèce apparentée aux canards dont le
bec long et 3 et bordés dans taille est
fait sur mesure pour attraper les
poissons aux écailles glissante
dans la phase ultime de leur cheminement
ses grands fleuves souvent ne maîtrisent
plus leur cours leurs lointains affluent
des montagnes ou gorgés d'eau rage
déverse d'énormes quantités d'eau qui
les font largement débordé chaque année
l'amazone connaît des crues qui n'ont de
des dizaines de milliers de kilomètres
carrés de forêt et qui lui font
atteindre en certains endroits
12 mètres de profondeur
les premiers à profiter de ces
inondations sont évidemment les poissons
qui y puisent des trésors de nourriture
supplémentaire arrivant au bout de leur
course à la mer les fleuves finissent de
déposer les sablés bout qu'ils ont
charrié sur des centaines des milliers
de kilomètres là les plantes aquatiques
et les poissons prolifèrent attirant des
nuées d'oiseaux comme un c soit des
neiges au nord du canada où ces autres
soi à l'autre bout du monde dans un
delta tropicale de papouasie nouvelle
guinée
le delta de l'amazone est immense étalé
sur plus de 300 kilomètres à travers ce
labyrinthe ce sont trois quarts des eaux
fluviales du globe qui vont finalement
rejoindre l'océan
c'est un monde aquatique intermédiaire
ni vraiment doux ni vraiment salée ou
les flots vont et viennent ou la terre
et l'eau sont en continuelle des
placements un monde aux frontières
duquel la lune
décrivant son orbite autour de la terre
provoquent deux fois par jour les
grandes marées océaniques
en même temps qu elle érode les côtes
la mère dépose sur les plages des masses
de débris qui provoque au contraire une
avancée de la terre sous les tropiques
les palétuviers croit sookie et l'océan
rassemble de la boue autour de leurs
racines et créent ainsi des territoires
nouveaux les mangroves où que ce soit
comme ici dans l'estuaire d'un fleuve
anglais lorsque l'eau douce rencontre
l'eau de mer elle dépose des sédiments
remplis de nourriture qui attire
aussitôt de nouveaux habitants ce petit
crustacé le corps fiom mesure 1 cm
environ il se nourrit de bactéries qui
prolifèrent par millions brisant les
substances organiques qui pourrissent
dans la boue les nereis sont des verts
qui vivent dans des trous il s'attaque
aux coraux fiom se nourrissent d'algues
de bactéries pratiquement de tout ce qui
se déplacent autour d'eux sur les
marques flotte un mucus produit par des
coquillages en forme de tête de flèche
pas plus grande que des grains de blé le
mucus attire les bactéries et les
coquillages mange le tout
à l'abri dans son tube là sa belle une
espèce de verre elle aussi déploie ses
tentacules pour attraper des particules
organiques en chute lente vers le fond
les filaments de l'éventail sont en
continuelle mouvement afin de faire
descendre les particules vers l'orifice
buccale situé au centre de cette sorte
de tube en même temps qu'elle se nourrit
elle et jette un ciment debout et de
mucus qui consolident leur bord du tube
la coque repose sur le fond avec sakho
qui béante
elles filtrent l'eau en respirant à
travers un siphon et en l'achat sans à
travers un autre les moules utilise la
même technique pour récolter à
l'intérieur de leur coquille des
particules nutritive
la marée en se retirant exposé certains
coquillages des milliers se trouvent
parfois rassemblés sur une surface d'un
mètre carré tous ces mangeurs de bout
constitue une prise très riche et les
amateurs ne manquent pas
les bécasseaux en migration s'en
régalent et 7 à longueur d'année que les
échassiers viennent s'alimenter aux
estuaires
la barge bénéficient de grandes pattes
et d'un long bec qui lui permettent
d'évoluer et de se nourrir dans des eaux
profondes de plusieurs centimètres le
courlis préfère travailler au sec
son bec et fils et lui permet de sonder
la boue en profondeur pour y attraper
des verts
le bécasseau variables plus petit
recherche des prises à sa mesure des
larves d'insectes
le gravelot n'a qu'un très petit bec et
ne peut saisir que de la nourriture
flottant en surface
en général il travaille en solitaire de
manière que sa proie ne soit pas alertés
par d'autres piétinement de pâtes
quant à la beauce est celle par un
mouvement de fauchage de son bec
recourbé qu'elle attrape les créatures
vivent dans la boue liquide à mesure que
les fleuves y apporte de nouveaux
sédiments les marécages augmente en
largeur et en profondeur
développant à leur surface une croûte
limoneuses d'algues microscopiques qui
entame le processus de consolidation
rapidement des plantes plus grande et
implantent leurs racines celles la
salicorne
ensuite le processus accélère la marée
montante apporte de nouvelles particules
de boue qui s'accumulent autour des
tiges de salicorne et qui ne repartiront
pas avec le reflux ainsi à chaque marée
les marécages prospère de plus en plus
profond la salicorne pousse dans les
estuaires froid de l'europe sous les
tropiques les colonisateurs debout ne
sont pas de petites plantes mais de
véritables arbres les palétuviers dont
il existe aujourd'hui une quarantaine
d'espèces différentes
les fleurs de ces palétuviers sont
pollinisées par le vent la graine ne
quitte pas immédiatement son arbre
d'origine elie entame son développement
en produisant une pousse verte d'une
trentaine de centimètres avec une
extrémité et filer si elle tombe à marée
haute
elle flotte horizontalement et peut
parcourir des kilomètres avant de
s'échouer
si elle tombe à marée basse elle se
plante dans la boue et le retour des
eaux ne l'en délogera pas rapidement
elle développe des radis kull vers le
bas des feuilles vers le haut et en
l'espace de quelques jours elle est
fermement installée même si cela ne
paraît pas évident le père et oft
allemand est un poisson
il en existe plusieurs espèces celui ci
vit près des lignes de marée haute et il
passe l'essentiel de son temps hors de
l'eau il doit conserver sa peau humide
car c'est à travers elle qu'ils
absorbent l'oxygène
il conserve également la bouche pleine
d'eau pour en alimenter de temps à autre
ses branchies il se nourrit de petits
crabes qu'il trouve dans la boue
une autre espèce vit près des lignes de
marée basse et ne passe hors de l'eau
qu'une heure ou deux par jour elle
tamise la boue liquide à la recherche de
verre et de petits crustacés une
troisième espèce enfin la plus courante
et qui est végétarienne s'alimente
d'algues et autres plantes
microscopiques
ceux ci protège leur territoire avec
vigueur en l'entourant de fortifications
et cela jusqu'à former un patchwork de
réservoir cloisonné ces appartements
plat et peu profond impose aux périodes
calmes de curieuses gymnastique à
l'heure de la quête amoureuse quand
enfin le mal a réussi à convaincre une
femelle de le rejoindre dans son bassin
privé il peut continuer à lui faire sa
cour de manière plus conventionnelle
autour des racines de palétuviers les
crabes appelant ou crabe violoniste sont
en pleine activité
les femelles ramasse de la boue avec
leurs deux pinces et la mâche à une
cadence d'enfer
les mâles en consomme la même quantité
mais ils ne disposent pour la récolter
que d'une seule passe
l'autre est à ce point développé qu'elle
leur est inutile dans leur exercice de
mastication
en fait elle ne leur sert qu'à faire
signe aux femelles de passage pour les
encourager à les suivre dans leurs trous
lorsque vous aurez un petit moment
arrêtez-vous de mâcher de la boue est
passé dont me voir
à marée basse
la nourriture ne manquent pas autour des
palétuviers les sternes chasse le poids
sont plus faciles à attraper maintenant
que les oeufs sont moins profondes
les martins pêcheurs font quant à eux
une grande consommation de crabes
appelant avec la marée montante arrivent
de nouveaux bancs de poissons
des poissons avides de ce que le fleuve
aurait pu déposer à marée basse
dans les marécages du sud est asiatique
le toc saute ou poisson archers se
nourrit d'insectes
il a une façon bien à lui de les
attraper par un rapide coup de langue
ils leur expédie un jet de gouttelettes
comme le ferait un pistolet à eau
l'étourdie l'insecte dombes à la surface
de l'eau ou le tox up s'empresse de le
gober